welcome back everyone so last time we
talked about the linear system of
equations X dot equals ax plus bu where
X is a state vector that describes the
state of the system and U is a set of
input signals so these are our control
knobs that we can use to hopefully
modify the behavior and the dynamics of
X ok and if the last time we came to
this controllability matrix so curly c
is a matrix given by the columns in B
followed by the columns and a B followed
by the columns in a squared B all the
way up to a to the N minus 1 B and we
have this simple relationship so I
haven't told you why yet but we have a
simple relationship that if the rank of
this controllability matrix equals n so
in some sense if the number of linearly
independent columns of this equals n
which is the dimension of my state so X
is in our n if the rank of this
controllability matrix is n the
dimension of my state space then this is
true if and only if the system system is
controllable and that's exactly how we
say it controllable ok so the system is
controllable if and only if the rank of
this controllability matrix is n meaning
that there are n linearly independent
directions in this this this matrix ok
and what I want to tell you now and this
is also very easy to check in MATLAB so
in MATLAB I would literally type in rank
of CTR B of a comma B ok and
controllable CTR B of a comma B gives me
this matrix and then rank checks the
rank
okay so if this equals n then the system
is controllable so it's a very simple
binary test of controllability that you
can use in MATLAB for your particular
system and you can see if it's
controllable
okay and so what I want to show you now
is that there are three equivalent
things things that are equivalent to
controllability okay so there are some
equivalences that are extremely
important so it's an equivalent some
equivalences okay one the system is
controllable the system is controllable
that's one if the system is controllable
and only if the system is controllable
then I can arbitrarily place the poles
anywhere I want so I get arbitrary and
when I say poles I mean eigenvalues
arbitrary eigenvalue sometimes this is
called pole these eigenvalues are called
poles for historical reasons but I get
arbitrary eigen value placements given
some u equals minus KX then I have X dot
equals a minus BK X I can place the
poles of this closed-loop system
anywhere I want if you give me n
distinct eigen values that you want the
system to have so if let's say that this
is the inverted pendulum and it's
unstable and you want to use feedback to
make it stable so that stays upright you
can pick any eigen values you want from
the closed-loop system and there exists
a matrix of gains K so that this
closed-loop system will have those
specified eigen values that's truly
remarkable okay
if the system is controllable and only
if the system is controllable you can
place the eigen values of your
closed-loop system anywhere you want
this is arbitrary eggs that's really
really remarkable okay now the third
thing that this is all equivalent to the
third thing is what we call reach
ability
okay so reach ability and I haven't
defined this yet so I'm about to reach
ability and so basically what this means
is that if the system is controllable
then I can cook up some control and put
you
we'll fear my system to any state X in
RN okay so let me just say that one more
time these are all completely equivalent
if one is true than the other is all
then the others are also true and here I
mean full reach ability full reach
ability in R and so I can reach any
vector in RN given some control input
and so let me just define this real
quick so the reachable set the reachable
set and we're going to call this curly
are at teeth so the set of states that
are reachable at time T this is equal to
all vectors in RN such that there is an
input U of T so that X at time T equals
C okay I hope that this makes sense so
the set the reachable set of states in
RN are all of the states in R and all of
the all of the the vectors in state
space where there exists some input U of
T that drives my system to that state C
at time T okay
and so this reachable set is all of the
states that I can drive my state to
using some control and so the idea here
is that if the system is controllable
then the reachable sets are T equals all
of our n which is really awesome that
means I can drive my system state
anywhere in RN with some U of T okay and
so these three these three facts are
essentially equivalent if the system is
controllable which is easy to check
using this rank condition then you can
arbitrarily place the poles of the
clothing system anywhere you want really
amazing for designing this closed-loop
system so you can design this to have
whatever stability or performance
you want and it also means that if the
system is controllable then there exists
a control input that will drive the
system to any state you want in a finite
amount of time okay so that's pretty
cool this this arbitrary eigenvalue
placement in matlab we're going to find
that this is using it's really easy
using the command place so essentially
it's going to be something like K equals
place a comma B and then some list of
desired eigenvalues okay so it will give
you the gain matrix K for your a and B
matrices and a specified set of desired
eigenvalues so again in that lab this is
a one-liner now one thing that I think
is really remarkable and maybe a little
hard to understand at first is how this
reachable set can be all of our n like
how can I go as far as I want in any
state direction if the system is
controllable and so what I like to think
about to start is let's say that I start
with I start with some let's say I have
like a unit sphere okay I've got some
unit sphere and I have some you know so
all of these C's live in this unit
sphere so this is in r3 my example I can
draw in r3 so if the reachable set is
inside of this sphere meaning I can get
to any point on the surface of the
sphere in RN with unit length given some
input in time the fact that this is a
linear system means that if I want to go
ten times farther in that direction all
I have to do is multiply this u by 10 I
have to make my input ten times bigger
and my state will be ten times bigger so
if u of t is ten times bigger X of T is
also ten times bigger so if I'm
reachable in all of the directions in RN
I can go arbitrarily far in any of those
directions just by making my input U as
big as I want okay
now this is the limitation of a linear
representation
and is that we know that for example if
I'm driving a car I can't just get from
here to Los Angeles in one second just
by hitting the gas really really hard I
can't just make you a billion times
bigger and expect to get to my
destination a billion times faster but
that's actually because of nonlinear
effects that are not modeled here okay
but at least in this linear framework as
long as this is valid if I can reach
some direction in RN I can go as far as
I want by just making my control uncut
bigger okay but the upshot is that there
are these three kind of equivalent
properties of a controllable system if
the system is controllable then the rank
of the controllability matrix equals n
which kind of means that with this input
B I can reach all directions in RN in
fact that means that with some I can
cook up a control and put you that will
steer my system to any vector in RN and
it also means that I can arbitrarily
place the eigenvalues of my close link
system to be anywhere I want and there's
a couple of catches like I can't have
too many repeated eigenvalues I can't
have more repeated eigenvalues than I
have columns of B so as long as these
are distinct eigenvalues I can get away
with with placing these eigenvalues
anywhere I want so for example if I have
an unstable system like the inverted
pendulum I can drive the eigenvalues
into the stable left half plane using
this pole placement and in fact using a
very simple one-line in MATLAB okay so
next time we're going to understand a
little bit more about this
controllability matrix what it means for
a system to be controllable or not
controllable and what it means to have
degrees of controllability and we'll
also come up with some alternative tests
to this rank condition that are a little
bit more illuminating all right thank
you